Once you have the perspective
that life isdance,
You'll begin to see dance everywhere
around you, all day long, like I do.
When Ichoreograph for film,
television and commercials,
I often generate moves that are
based on the humanexperience.
I take these moves, I string them together,
twist and play with their pace,
in orderto create more meaningful work.
Here's a music video, "Chandelier,"
that I choreographed for Sia,
featuring the incredible dancer Maddie Ziegler.
And fork, fork, fork, stab it in the wall,
toss it and pass out, come to and look;
Charlie Chaplin, Charlie Chaplin,
cockroachup the wall,
clean your mustache,
a possum, sink ...
Is it time for lunch yet?
I'd loveto invite you to be
your own choreographer.
Let fun and laughter push the
boundaries ofridiculousness.
Who knows?
Maybe brushing your teeth or
whisking up mac and cheese
will become your new favorite dance move.